welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
latest trailer for doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness dreams which i
first watched in a dream like state
since i was up at 5 50 a.m refreshing
amc's glitchy app trying to get tickets
for this movie order creation failed
yeah more like nicole kidman needs a
whole rotor herself from classic disney
easter eggs to third eyes to the return
of billy and tommy proving we all gotta
re-watch one division there's just so
much to unpack here so let's go through
this frame by frame let's go
i've been
dreaming
every night
and every morning the same
nightmare
all right imagery of strangest nightmare
is now scored by the everly brothers
1958 song all i have to do is dream one
division actually featured oldie hits
with the monkeys daydream believer in
its trailer and another 1958 song yakity
yak by the coasters in episode 1 which
judging from the calendar the kitchen
that episode was set in 1961 the year
that the dick van dyke show premiered
here the everly brothers lyrics reflect
wanda's tragic longing for her children
and vision when i want you in my arms
when i want you and all your charms
whenever i want you all i have to do is
dream
dream dream dream dream drink and it's
not just her son's wanda once but one of
her sons billy as wiccan can cast his
own actual charms a new shot shows
strange waking up and that holding cell
fresh scratches on his head and chunky
cuffs around his wrists but not yet
bound like we saw in the other shot
these cuffs appear to be powered by
something that emits a green glow a
color that an mcu passed has been
associated with the time stone and with
classic loki's glorious purpose conjured
city while fighting goliath these cuffs
could be used to confine or id a
particular variant as strange as
voiceover speaks an awesome audio effect
transitions his voice into wandas every
night
and every morning
the same
nightmare which we could interpret to
mean that strange might be being
puppeted by wanda in that moment or they
could just be feeling parallel hauntings
and now wanda is usurping his power by
taking the literal words out of his
mouth we see wanda in a new cardigan
outfit in her west view home from
wandavision single cam set from episodes
six and seven as billy and tommy return
actors julian hilliard and jet cline
julian throughout all of our twitter
interactions you kept this under wraps
well done young man now remember the one
division post-credits scene showed
wanda's astral form reading the darkhold
searching for her sons who called out to
her for help
now we're seeing what we think is a
reunion with them but really is another
false illusion someone or something is
taunting wanda with the dream of a
reality where she could have her kids
again wanda does say the word nightmare
here nightmare being the name of a
marvel demonic entity but i have a
feeling it's going to be cathon now
billy and tommy are as they were often
in one division back in their comics
colors billy aka wigan in red tommy aka
speed and green and then a fire roars in
a hearth directly behind them definitely
ain't safe for two kids who have started
this alone fire hell
not today mephisto don't do this to me
again master but i am obligated to
remind you that in the comics these two
are revealed to be demon spawn puppeted
by a servant to mavisto something marvel
could choose to make canon if they want
to give me the best birthday present
which it is today april 7th so please go
light on the mephisto names today thanks
really my favorite easter egg is on the
tv behind them an old black and white
animated short that i thought initially
could have been steamboat willy but this
ain't mickey mouse this is oswald and
ortenzia from the 1928 short to
skyscrapers if you know your disney
history walt disney produced oswald
shorts for universal before partying
ways of our contract dispute and then
went on to create mortimer mouse later
renamed mickey mouse who famously
starred in steamboat willy in 1929
taking over the world from there forward
but over the years oswald gained a cult
following as mickey's forgotten
predecessor erased from memory and then
kind of later rediscovered and
reappreciated as a real victim of studio
machinations you could actually draw a
comparison between oswald and artensia
and vision in wanda who were also
background heroes who seem to have
missed their window but thanks to one
division re-emerged as the mcu's
dominant power couple like oswald vision
has been killed off and then resurrected
for profit and now has a committed
following of those devoted to his memory
including wanda now wanda holds billy
and tommy in her arms in this cool
sideways shot that cuts to her arms
suddenly in the blink of an eye empty in
this seance confirming that that seance
was to connect with her dream reality of
her two sons back in her west view house
now notice how most of the candles
around her that were previously lit in
the seance shot are now extinguished
except for two of them perhaps all of
these candles represented possible
billys and tommies throughout the
multiverse then as she narrowed it down
to two that she thought were her two
sons to remain lit as wanda says the
word nightmare her russian accent
returns or i should say her sokovian
accent something that mysteriously faded
between the events of age of ultron and
civil war and infinity war but as we
learned in juanavision was really the
results of her binging american sitcoms
with vision and avengers compound as
they learned that grief is love
perseverance so shut your mouths still
that accent came back in choice moments
when she dwelled on the events of age of
ultron the accents returned now could
indicate wanda back in that vengeful
headspace and since in this movie we
will be seeing two wandas the accent
could be another way this movie
distinguishes which which is which now
it can be hard to see the light at the
end of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can even
be harder to ask for help well that's
where upstart comes in upstart power and
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you are
more than just your credit score so
rather than looking at your credit score
alone upstart's model considers other
factors like your income employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate in
minutes for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars without
impacting your credit score you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan don't wait
and check your rate today at upstart.com
new rockstars that's upstart.com new
rockstars to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you go to upstart.com new
rockstars moving on
the freight of the multiverse
depends on us
okay there's now a new shot of the ruins
that i believe to be the utopian
parallel america chavez's home dimension
then at the center on this pedestal is a
glowing blue item hard to tell but it
looks kind of like the dark hole we also
see more of this dimensions architecture
a snaking rainbow road in the upper left
corner and then on the right a spherical
crystalline structure that looks like
the light source of the space then
another new-ish spot that released over
the weekend a hulking beast behind wong
that many thought was cathode but if you
look closely at the shot of wanda as i
pointed out there is another one of
these beasts behind her so based on
there being two of them i'm less
confident that this is fun reminder of
on the elder god who sometimes looks
like this who originally cursed wanda
with her chaos magic and was the
original author of the darkhold but
rather these could be catholic's minions
the ingary elder spawn demons created by
kethan and banished to another
dimensional plane but here notice how
their eyes glow red wanda could be
controlling them here and since there
are two of them at least in this shot i
just have to wonder if these might have
been the life forms that cathode used to
base billy and tommy on but their
physical corporeal forms are actually
these demons the ingarra look i know
it's crazy but the one division
producers did confirm senor scratchy the
rabbit was actually agatha's familiar
who was supposed to shapeshift back into
a monstrous demon just like this so who
knows billy and tommy could truly be the
demon spawn unleashing hell then there's
that other new-ish spot that i've talked
about before doctor strange in the
gargantos battle in front of that
building with a sign for stan lee which
i just think might be a nod to stan lee
just because they paid tribute to him
exactly this way with stanley's pizza in
the 2008 hulk though i know the sign
could also be something else but any
time i see the word stanley and the imps
i'm gonna say it's a stan lee reference
all right so shut up and then that
awesome shot from the super bowl tv spot
of christine palmer in the illuminati
lab with american chavez and the holding
cell as other lab techs flee and ultron
sentries charge forward so many crazy
things happening at once but i'm gonna
add another one to it new detail in the
doorway behind her it opens up to the
manhattan skyline folks that is the
chrysler building so this multiversal
citadel that is modeled on the british
museum it is located just like the
sanctum sanctorum is right in the middle
of manhattan but higher up over the
skyline making me wonder if it could be
hidden in a pocket reality in the
building that was once avengers tower
which has a great view of chrysler tower
just like this does the illuminati folks
could be headquartered in a british
museum-y pocket reality in the fantastic
four's new baxter building which would
fit nicely with our speculation that one
of those illuminati members could be
reed richards okay on to the last
section
careful stephen
this path exacts a heavy toll
[Music]
okay
marvel studios knocked her straight to
the multiverse of madness get a few more
shots from the super bowl tv spot and
then mordo unsheathing his glowing sword
but then yikes sinister strange from the
december trailer has a third eye open
from his forehead this could be a
literal version of the mystical third
eye that was alluded to by the ancient
one open your eye
i've used that to speculate that the
reason strange might have his eye of
agamotto once more is that like in the
comics there could actually be three of
these necklaces in an interview with
bandango sam raimi would not say
explicitly who the villain of this movie
was but he did hint that it would be an
altered strange but he also indicated
that at different points in the movie
all the characters variants could be
hostile antagonists as strange ventures
out into other realities figures out how
they rhyme with our reality in our
complete opposites or somewhere in
between lastly there's this new close-up
of the rotting face of defender strange
at the mountaintop battle which i
believe to be atop wounded horror
mountain which is where catholic's
darkhold temple is kept the way strange
twitches his head and looks directly at
us it's so freaky sam raimi said in that
interview that he wanted to embrace the
original pitches from kevin feige and
the first director scott derrickson who
is credited as a producer on this movie
that this should be a horror film but he
would not yet confirm if his evil dead
front man bruce campbell was making a
cameo but we all know the guy's gonna
show up and uh hey while i got your
attention here if you live in the san
francisco bay area i'm gonna start
performing live comedy again with the
hilarious folks of endgames improv not
mcu related but there will probably be
some nerdy voices at some point shows
starting regularly in may but tomorrow
april 8th will be a free preview student
show at 6 00 p.m at the stage works
theater at 446 valencia street in the
mission come check it out i'd love to
meet you you can follow me on instagram
and twitter at boss follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you
[Music]